doctors and nurse is outside their
Hospital they've been on strike for
nearly a month protesting against the
new health law called MTI
the provincial government says it will
reform hospitals in the way they're
managed protesters accused the
government of using the reforms as a
disguise to privatize the health care
system in Heiberg Pakhtunkhwa Pakistan
it's not acceptable to us we know it's
the poor patients suffering because of
the strike but we don't have an option
our future is at stake government-run
hospitals in the province are at a
standstill
wards are empty staff for staying at
home only emergency services are
operating but staff are severely
overstretched the striking doctors and
nurses fear the changes will mean
redundancies and patients will be
charged for their treatment
Yes Prime Minister Imran Khan promised
he'll provide more jobs in the new
Pakistan but we're now worried the new
law means no job security
last month protesters and police fought
outside of hospital and they now say
they'll stay on strike until the demands
are met the government now insists the
law will modernize hospitals whole
medical staff accountable and provide
affordable public health care I have
introduced a law that is ultimately
going to benefit the common man and just
because a certain group of people they
retaliate for their own personal
interests for their Western interests I
am NOT going to back off the largest
teaching hostel in the province has
already child the reforms one doctor
says the new system convinced him to
return home to Pakistan from the UK it
has given us institutional autonomy we
can do our own recruitment budgeting
equipment purchase we have established
new specialties so I think the patient
care has significantly improved while
the dispute goes on thousands of
patients in the province are unable to
get the treatment they need certified at
al Jazeera